a mecca furby showdown in vegas and evil
tickle me elmo and the spiderman cameo
were all cut from the final version of
the mitchells versus the machines
yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing the spectacular
alternate ending of the mitchell's movie
plus all the deleted scenes you never
got to see
spoilers ahead of course so take care
although in the final movie the
mitchells confront pal and her robot
army at the pal lab headquarters in
silicon valley
originally the final confrontation with
the ai villain was going to take
place in las vegas the movie's head of
story guillermo martinez revealed that
in an earlier version of the movie when
pal who was male at that point
discovered he was about to lose he
activated every appliance in the city
and used them to transform himself into
a giant mecca furby
who'll save humanity now searching
searching zero results found
and concept art from the movie shows how
this enormous mecca furby went on a
rampage through vegas as it chased the
mitchells in their car
eventually katie and her family would
have faced off against the mecca bot at
las vegas pyramid-shaped luxor which
they would have driven up the side of
and then katie would have launched
herself at the giant furby to take out
its reactor core
which reminds me of the moment in the
final movie where katie drives up the
pal building using monchi in an attempt
to deliver the kill
code before the pandemic the mitchells
was going to be released theatrically
and there were a couple of
toilet-related jokes from the first
trailer that ended up cut from the final
film when it was released on netflix
when the family stopped for a bathroom
break there was going to be a joke about
aaron's less than salubrious hygiene
habits
no time to wash your hands don't worry i
never do
however producer chris miller said that
joke felt irresponsible once the
pandemic hit
and so it ended up being changed to
something more innocuous
come on end of the world sorry false
alarm
i was just in there reading and there
was another deleted bathroom based gag
from that first trailer where a smart
robot toilet rebels against its human
user
sayonara the appliance attack at the
mall together with the furby army is one
of the best and most popular parts of
the movie
[Music]
however for a long time the animation
team couldn't get through to the right
people at hasbro for permission to use
furbies in the film
so they changed the scene to feature an
alternate set of evil robot toys instead
the leader in that version was a tickle
me elmo style plush toy called tickle me
melmo complete with an eye patch and
metal arm and his mana channeled
immortan joe from mad max fury road
commander what say you you bring wisdom
from an ancient time
and it has been written like lands to
the slaughter
in this version tickle me melmo also
commandeered a team of microwaves he
called the valkyries and ordered them to
launch themselves and destroy the
friendly robots eric and deborah bot who
are helping the mitchells
launch the valkyries the robots will be
destroyed i live
i die i live again
get down you sweet boys some of ticomi
melmo's creepy sidekicks that didn't
make it into the movie were reading
randall who won't deactivate
listens to everything and does what he
wants there was also
tea time tina who like randall not only
listens and spies on you but
also has a killer karate chop action of
course they eventually got hasbro's
approval to use the furbys but director
mike reander said that earlier versions
of the creepy furby army
used even darker language that implied
they feasted on flesh and were seemingly
sent by satan
in the final movie a pal-chipped toaster
ominously warns the mitchells of the
mayhem that's about to kick off however
originally there was going to be a
malicious toy puppy with demonic red
eyes which first
threatened the family attacked them and
then summoned the other appliances and
play things
including a toy helicopter race car and
wheelie duck a giant penguin and a jack
in the box
look matchy he's like you
humans your kindness forbidden in this
realm now prepare for your due
oh what is it gonna do bark at me to
death
the plastic is sharper than you would
think it's tougher than you would think
awaken brothers
[Music]
what's going on the friendly defective
robots eric and debra bot 5000 were a
wonderful pair of characters
and there was a funny and also sweet
deleted scene where linda teaches debra
boss a little more about what it means
to be part of a family
look at this foolish mother goose she's
slowed down by these small weak geese
why does she not simply eat them for
power
that's her family that's what we humans
do we look out for each other that is
most illogical well if you were in
trouble would you leave your buddy
behind
i i would not this is most curious
see we're more alike than are you eating
crayons
no thematically this deleted scene fits
well with the moment in the movie when
linda goes back to save eric
after he's trapped by a falling column
during the giant furby attack
thank you human are you now my mother by
the way i can't help but feel the moment
where linda catches deborah bosh
eating crayons and they deny it is a
little call back to mike rianda's short
film work which he made when he was
studying at cal arts
frank are you eating crayons no it
really looks like you are are you
calling me a liar it is somewhat brutal
but darkly very humorous deleted scene a
mysterious character called dirk
mctavish showed up briefly to rescue the
mitchells during the robot attack at the
dino stop
is everyone all right well now we are
the name's dirk mctavish 45th infantry
armed combat unit and i know the only
way
oh well that's a disappointment not for
me
his square jawed long-haired look
reminds me a bit of the leading man who
features on the dvd cover for robo
slayers 4.
and linda certainly seems into it i love
the little detail of a lock of his hair
waving in the breeze that the animators
put into this which adds to the overall
action movie star vive and just cracks
me up
although apparently the president of
sony animation found this scene
hilarious i wonder whether it was
ultimately cut for time and pacing and
perhaps as being a little dark or coming
out of nowhere for the end film
in the final movie the mitchells get
into pal labs hq by disguising
themselves as robots as per katie's
dope plan in an earlier version though
there was a humorous scene where the
family figured out what their best
camouflage options would be
what about katie
[Music]
how's this for camouflage i found these
parts lying around on the ground that's
a genius honey you're like a little
huntress you're getting it though are we
camouflaged guys you are freaking me out
the moments cut from the final movie
that we get a snippet of
in the first trailer occurs when the
mitchells are hiding from the robots in
the icebox at the dino stop
technology rising up this was part of a
longer monologue by rick about the
dangers of technology where he basically
said
i told you so according to producer phil
lord it ended up getting the chop
because it undermined the stakes and
perhaps makes rick's character less
likeable
the evil pal voiced by olivia coleman
made for an excellent villain
poke poke swipe pinch zoom [ __ ] bring me
pizza
baby taylor swift no i hate that song
give me some nachos
really work it into the crevices however
originally pal was going to be a
cloud-based computer brain which i think
might have made her feel more
reminiscent of the antagonist computer
hal
in 2001 a space odyssey which pal's name
and the robot's red dot already
referenced
the filmmakers realized that making her
an actual cell phone would be much
funnier and approached coleman to voice
the character based on her oscar-winning
performance in the favorite and her
ability to be incredibly funny then turn
on a dime to scream and be menacing
place me on the table i wish to flop
around in a blind rage
[Music]
many of the mitchells filmmakers
including producers phil lord and chris
miller were also involved in another of
sony's hit
animations spider-man into the
spider-verse and took inspiration from
some of the experimental style of that
film
which is likely why the mitchells versus
the machines almost had a spider-man
cameo
in an interview with inverse director
mike rianda said he tried to get a kind
of disheveled lumpy spider-man in the
background of a shot but the pressure
was on to just finish the movie
given the critical acclaim and
popularity of the mitchells though i
wouldn't be surprised if we see a
mitchell's easter egg or even cameo pop
up in a future spider-verse film
although we didn't get that spider-man
easter egg in the mitchells i found
well over a hundred other awesome
references easter eggs and secrets
hidden in the movie
tap here to discover all those in my
things you missed video or click the
link in the video description
and if you want to see more amazing
pieces of the mitchell's concept
art including alternate and deleted
scenes and character designs such as
lady monchi
check out the art of the mitchells
versus the machines book i'll add a link
where you can get a copy in the
description below
so do you wish any of these deleted
scenes had made it into the final film
comment below with your thoughts on the
movie and the cut scenes
and if you enjoyed this i really
appreciate a thumbs up and a share
you can tap left for all those
mitchell's movie easter eggs or tap
right for something else you're sure to
like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee kai movie lovers